hello everyone and welcome to the last
game will be showing from around 10 of
the 2013 candidates tournament it's
Alexander Greece vs. Vladimir Kramnik
and at the time this game was played it
caught a lot of media attention and I
will tell you why after this game and
then you will be able to decide for
ourselves if there's anything to this
story or maybe not so we'd only have two
photos from this round here is the photo
of kramnik before the game
waiting for a group to appear nothing
out of the ordinary in the photo and
here we have a photo from the the
opening was played and now it seems to
be greased up smooth and a nice photo
photo all in all so let's see this game
we have E 4 E 5 Knight to f3 knight c6
and Bishop to b5 the rule opus and of
course kramnik goes for the Berlin
defence we have Knight to f6 and it's
very interesting as kramnik did use the
Berlin defense to the feed Gary Kasparov
in their 2000 World Chess Championship
match Vladimir Kramnik is considered
somewhat of an expert in this opening
but it has the kramnik did say something
very interesting about this in an
interview after the game but I will
mention this after the game so we have
castles Knight captures on e4 let me
just take care of the sound Oh once
again I have wondered it ok that that
takes care of it
d4 Knight to d6 Bishop captures and c6
removing the defender of d5 pawn D
captures on c6 and now D captures an e5
Knight to a5 Queen captures on d8 team
captures the Queen's are now off the
board and Knight to c3 so this is the
standard line everyone has seen it a
thousand times and it's very hard for
whites to push here for something more
than a draw
you know black is very solid here and
especially since chronic is playing with
the black pieces then black is really
very solid here we have Bishop to d7 H 3
H 6 and rook to d1
and already you know how people say the
Berlin it's a very
very boring opening but it's already a
very poisonous position here King to see
it was played and King to see it okay
you might you might think okay I'm
getting out of the line of the road but
is there any immediate threat here you
know is this perhaps a waste of a temple
can't I make like a useful move and then
maybe later if I will have to move the
King only then move the King ah well
it's it's very hard to say
moving the King away from the this rooks
file is the best thing you can do if you
play a seemingly active move for example
like Bishop to c5 then you're
immediately losing the game it seems
like you know seems like you didn't do
anything wrong but in fact after Knight
to e4 there's a really no good place for
you to remove this bishop the bishop is
not defended on c5 and there's really
nowhere for you to put it Bishop to e7
you you you take away the only square
this Knight has G for will then trap the
night if you move it all the way to f8
then again g4 is coming after you move
Knight to e7 then you have this c6 idea
either you will lose the bishop or you
will capture and then after Knight to d5
again rook captures Bishop will be a
threat and on the other hand after
something like Bishop to c5 if you move
it the b6 sorry if you move it after 94
if you move it to b6 then you get c4 a
very poisonous move you definitely don't
want to allow c5 because then g4 and nd6
are coming so c5 and making room for
this knight on d4 but it doesn't help
you G for a night here knife characters
pawn captures c5 is coming Bishop to a5
and now rook captures and before again
you're threatening b4 to capture the
bishop here and after you make room for
the bishop then again you get Bishop
captures in age 6 or pretty much sure
White has a lot of options here but
simply making rook room for the rook
will give white a beautiful position
that will be sufficient to win the game
so yeah seemingly you know a peaceful
opening there's a lot of poison to it so
after rook to d1 King to c8
if you're a Berlin player
you know just move your king don't make
her life difficult we have a 4 a 5 B 3
now and the B 6 Bishop to b2 9 3 7 rook
to d2 and c5 now nice to e2 Knight the
g6 rotated be one with a double attack
on the bishop here Bishop to e6 now and
c4 so already you can see that the Queen
side is completely blocked there's
really nothing to hope for here so you
have to look for play and on either
either in the middle of the board or on
the King side Bishop to e7 unites the c3
there are maybe some ideas of night
sorry night the b5 or Knight d5 in the
future came to b7 making room for the a8
rook to enter the game and now Knight to
d5 attacking the bishop on e7 rook a to
d8 Knight captures on e7 rook captures
on d2 Knight captures Knight captures on
e7 and now 92 f1 early maneuvering
tonight and now keeping control of the D
file with the rook King to c8 and not
allowing this rook any activity and now
rook to d8 is coming Kramnik is
preparing to exchange even more pieces
we have f3 knock offs g5 night the g3
and rook to d8 rook captures and King
captures and here you have a pretty
standard position it's a push up against
Knight on both sides the position is
pretty equal Kramnik does have doubled
pawns but it's nothing serious that wood
that will give YTD advantage and there
are opposite colored bishops so if the
Knights come off the board it's it will
be very hard to achieve anything with
either side so it would be very hard to
imagine that cross either chronic or
grip would actually win this game but
you know it's just anything can happen
so let's see what happened King to have
to by Glee shook Bishop to f5
Knight captures Knight captures and g4
now attacking the knight here knife to
d4 was played and this is only moved 29
there are 11 more moves to be made to
reach time control and what do you do
here
well obviously Kramnik is preparing to
capture the b3 pawn so there's really no
good way to stop this and since well
this is why the game caught a lot of
attention obviously gristick allowed
this because he was planning Bishop
captures on d4 but the only good move
you have here perhaps not the only but
the best move for white is actually King
to e3 and now Knight captures some b3 is
possible but it it's not really all that
bad for white because after Knight
captures white will push east six give
yet another pawn and now if you capture
the pawn then Bishop to g7 will pick up
all of the Kings iPhones black has and
then white will be winning this game so
instead of actually capturing this upon
the King has to come help out with the
defense and after he captured team
captures then the bishop is isn't able
to come here
but now you can see that there are no
squares available for this night
so this Knight is unable to move
anywhere and white will be better in
this endgame
it's hard to say if what can actually
push for a win but white will be better
so it's very hard to understand the move
Grichuk made here here as you've seen so
it's not it's not a for a for a player
of Greece Excalibur it's not a move that
he would miss but he played a bunch of
captures on d4 so of course chronic
recaptured we have C capture some before
and this was actually the move that lost
Greece shoot the game because now after
King to e2 we have King to d7 King to d3
c5 now defending the d4 pawn King to e4
it seems like White's King is more
active but after King to e6 now you have
this classic situation where there are
no useful moves for white so white
doesn't have a single useful move for a
spawn and black will have a useful move
for respond if white decides to move the
King then black will simply capture the
e5 pawn so white has to make a pawn move
the only move pawn move that doesn't
lose the game I mean it does but
seemingly doesn't is f4 so Grisha plays
this G capture screen captures and now
comes the move that of course it's it's
very hard to imagine that the Greek
would miss such a move from that
position where he played better of
capture
and v4 but since you are already such an
excellent and again player I'm sure you
don't even have to pause the video to
find chronic small here it's but you
don't feel free to pause it and of
course if you found it I don't know if
it's if it's ok to even congratulate you
because I know you already saw the move
before I even told you to pause the
video but ok if you found this
congratulations you are an excellent in
the end Wow
end game player and if you just want to
enjoy the show then of course the move
is d3 and this is a pretty standard idea
in in King and pawn and games where
white doesn't have any useful moves and
black does so d3 the King has to stop
the point you cannot allow d2 so King t3
was played and now comes King captures
on e5 can capture Sun b3 and now King to
f4 we have King to e2 now comes King to
g3 King to e3 of course there's nothing
white can do to prevent black from
capturing the points King captures King
before defending we have King to h5 and
after King to f5 King to g3 was played
and it was in this position that
Alexander Ganesha resigned the game here
is done because as you can see the king
is covering it for the points covering
g5 so the King has to move away from the
pawn after King moves Kramnik will
simply gobble up the g5 the g4 pawn and
after King captures an f7 then the H
bone will simply win the game easily so
yeah after King to g3 there was nothing
and there was nothing you could do and
he resigned the game so this was the you
know the topic of all discussions did
Greece should really miss Bishop capture
son before because you've seen in the in
the game between cram against wheeler
everyone would was saying that Svidler
threw the game so crummy could you know
catch up to cross and faster
you know like Russians working together
and then they were saying you know wait
till you see kram next game against the
gritty shook and you know who would have
known that such a physician will occur
and that really shook will seemingly
throw the game but you know blunders
happen you know it's
blind spots happen anything happens in
chess so I mean of course people will
say you know a lot of things but I don't
think anything like this happened it was
I mean seems like seems like a perfectly
reasonable blunder but yeah it did
happen and it did raise a lot of
suspicions so that was the game I do
hope you enjoyed it and we do have the
standings as this is the last game will
be showing from round 10 so here it is
after round 10 Magnus Carlsen is in
first place with seven points then we
have Aragon with six and a half and I
did receive further even further
confirmation from subscribers from
Armenia that I am in fact pronouncing
eleven Iranian correctly so just wanted
to say that with six and a half we have
allowed me of kramnik with six after
this win against Alexander Grichuk then
Grisha put four and a half get funded
with four and a half Svidler with four
and a half and then he went to endure a
job of in last place with three and a
half points so a couple of more rounds
to go into 2013 candidates tournament I
do hope you're enjoying the coverage so
far I would like to thank Barry van
Leuven for a contribution to my channel
sorry I forgot to add the amount of our
contribution yesterday I have no idea
how that happened
comments are navorski and ft grant also
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot - really appreciate it
as usual you can check - on my previous
videos here thank all for watching and I
will see you soon with a couple of nice
games from round 11 of the 2013 Cadiz
tournament thank you all and I'll see
you soon